[Musica]
quando mi immagino il futuro nella mia
mente si accende sempre l'immagine di un
fiume
il futuro è quel tratto di fiume che
scorre lontano da me verso l'orizzonte
ma che nella mia testa so anche molto
collegato al presente
le sponde il tratto di fiume che sto
osservando io in questo momento è quel
futuro e questo presente sono a loro
volta collegati con il prima con la
storia con il tratto a monte con la
sorgente costituendo quindi passato
presente e futuro un unicum un continuum
fluviale il fiume se ci pensate con
un'azione di fatto molto semplice erode
trasporta deposita è un cesellatore di
paesaggi un creatore di paesaggi
incredibile ha dalla sua il tempo secoli
millenni milioni di anni un tempo lungo
che il fiume utilizza indirettamente per
modellare i paesaggi il tempo anche il
tempo possiamo immaginarselo come una
sorta di nastro trasportatore
immaginario in cui negli ultimi 200
forse 300 mila anni la storia di homo
sapiens la nostra storia un nastro
trasportatore che ha fatto salire e
scendere persone popoli comunità con le
loro capacità le loro propensioni le
loro conoscenze conoscenze capacità che
in qualche modo hanno plasmato anche il
rapporto tra uomo e natura rapporto tra
uomo e natura su cui anche se
inconsapevolmente l'uomo ha aperto una
grandissima scommessa per il futuro
qual è questa scommessa per il futuro
nel rapporto uomo natura e modificare la
propria visione
la natura passare a un approccio di
conoscenza tale che ci permetta di
creare un nuovo rapporto tra uomo e
natura
beninteso uomo e natura coesistono e
interagiscono dagli albori della storia
dell'uomo da 300 mila anni fa prima
l'uomo era un inconsapevole pedina
all'interno di questo grandissimo
meccanismo adesso ci siamo in parte
svincolati riusciamo a gestire parte di
questi meccanismi complessi della natura
parte dei meccanismi non tutti i
complessi meccanismi della natura ci
manca un elemento essenziale la
conoscenza non conosciamo nel dettaglio
tutti gli elementi di questo complesso
ecosistema di questo complesso
meccanismo di interazione la conoscenza
la conoscenza è un nuovo una nuova
modalità di vedere il rapporto uomo
natura
in questo contesto assume un ruolo
fondamentale e importante la
biodiversità
cos'è la biodiversità la biodiversità
sono la varietà di piante di cespugli di
erbe di microorganismi di invertebrati
di vertebrati insomma tutta o quella
insieme numerosissimo e vasto
gli organismi viventi grandi o piccoli
che essi siano che occupano e vivono sul
nostro pianeta
una varietà enorme creata nel corso di
milioni di anni di evoluzione
l'evoluzione una spinta verso il
cambiamento verso gli adattamenti verso
una ampia diversità
la natura è un valore anche per i
servizi che ci offre i cosiddetti
servizi ecosistemici cioè cosa riusciamo
a trarre dalla natura che ci serve nella
quotidianità per inventare per
programmare per vivere in ultima analisi
che rapporto c'è tra la biodiversità ei
servizi ecosistemici servizi
ecosistemici anche anch'essi devono
essere assoggettati a una nuova visione
dobbiamo imparare a sfruttare i servizi
della natura preservando la macchina
erogatrice di queste servizi ossia la
natura stessa
dicevo che rapporto c'è tra natura tra
servizi ecosistemici e biodiversità
immaginatevi un sistema di trasferimento
dell'informazione a rete confrontato con
un sistema di trasferimento
dell'informazione da punto a punto
in caso di un guasto il trasferimento
dell'informazione una sorta di rete
internet a rete garantisce come comunque
il passaggio dell'informazione da un
punto all'altro sfruttando le varie
connessioni disponibile un guasto su una
connessione da punto a punto
inevitabilmente blocca il servizo ecco
ambienti a elevata biodiversità sono
ambienti che hanno un'elevatissima
capacità di resilienza cioè di far
fronte di rispondere a perturbazioni che
arrivano dall'esterno del sistema
offrendo quindi servizi ecosistemici
migliori cosa sono questi servizi
ecosistemici talvolta sono talmente di
uso quotidiano che non ci facciamo
nemmeno più caso
l'acqua potabile che beviamo l'ossigeno
indispensabile per la nostra vita
o quella sensazione di benessere
psicofisico che abbiamo quando siamo
immersi in ambienti ben conservati
ambienti ben conservati che anche se
indirettamente hanno un ruolo
fondamentale non solo per il nostro
benessere ma in generale per la nostra
salute
e se vogliamo fare un elenco di questi
servizi ecosistemici di questi prodotti
che possiamo utilizzare che provengono
da interazioni complesse dalla natura
l'elenco sarebbe sterminato faremo qui
giorni vi faccio solo alcuni aneddoti ad
esempio quelle piante che basano la
produzione dei loro frutti quindi il
loro ciclo vitale in parte o totalmente
sull'interazione con alcune specie di
pipistrelli grazie all'in pauline azione
o alla dispersione dei frutti dei semi e
per la produzione dei frutti
la banana mango la papaya il durian un
frutto che per noi europei fa
letteralmente schifo ma è una
prelibatezza per i popoli asiatici o il
caffè che ci permette di produrre una
bevanda internazionalmente nota ma
possiamo spingerci oltre e andare ad
esaminare quelle sostanze naturali che
sono state scoperte e quindi utilizzate
anche nel campo della salute umana
ad esempio una molecola con proprietà
anti coagulanti che c'è nella saliva dei
pipistrelli vampiri che io sinceramente
preferisco chiamare pipistrelli
ematofagi mangiatori di sangue e tre
specie in sudamerica non in transilvania
una molecola che in grado di sgrigna e
disgregare i coaguli sanguigni
dopo il fenomeno ischemico fino a 9 ore
dopo la formazione dei coaguli a
differenza di una finestra utile di soli
e 4 ore delle normali sostanze di
sintesi
oppure il tasso lo una sostanza naturale
scoperta negli anni sessanta estratta
dalla pianta di tasso che viene usata
nelle terapie
tumorali per contrastare il cancro
ovarico mammario e qui si aggiunge un
altro valore che mi rendo conto può
sembrare metafisica ma il valore di
opzione della biodiversità cos'è il
valore di opzione in natura ci sono
attualmente un sacco di sostanze che noi
non sappiamo come usare perché non le
conosciamo noi l'abbiamo ancora scoperte
esattamente come il tasso lo prima degli
anni 60 ma che potenzialmente potrebbero
essere sfruttate dare dei servizi utili
serve maggiore conoscenza se lei
perdessimo avremmo perso un patrimonio
valore ed opzione frutti e pipistrelli
molecole e salute umana
quando andiamo analizzare questi aspetti
di fatto su cosa poniamo l'accento cosa
sottoliniamo cosa poniamo in evidenza la
funzione che sia una funzione molecolare
a livello molecolare che sia una
funzione a livello eco sistemico poniamo
l'accento sulla funzione come funziona
un meccanismo in natura
che ruolo ha una specie in natura
andiamo verso quello che deve essere la
spinta per il futuro il superamento di
un approccio puramente estetico alla
natura privilegiando un approccio di
tipo funzionale in questo caso vedete
dei paesaggi addomesticati dall'uomo
rispetto dei paesaggi naturali
addomesticati dall'uomo con un criterio
puramente estetico ci piacciono di più
ma la funzione eco sistemica di quei
paesaggi è uguale alla funzione degli
ecosistemi naturali e se dobbiamo andare
verso un superamento dell'approccio
estetico verso i paesaggi ancor più lo
dobbiamo fare per le specie chiaro non
dico di abolire il rapporto estetico a
chiunque piace di più una specie
piuttosto che un'altra
ma dobbiamo andare oltre riuscire a
capire che ruolo hanno le specie in
natura
che ruolo svolgono questa necessità di
informazione è emersa prepotentemente
negli ultimi anni anche tra i cittadini
europei
poi ovviamente anche noi cittadini
italiani che dicono di aver necessità di
saperne di più in campo scientifico e
tra le varie discipline scientifiche
prevale ovviamente il campo medico per
ovvie ragioni di prossimità ma subito
dopo c'è necessità di saperne di più
sulla biodiversità e sull'ambiente in
generale la conoscenza conoscere come
funzionano i meccanismi indirettamente
questo ci porta già ad avere un
superamento dell'approccio estetico
verso la natura
vado in natura trovo un capriolo
abbandonato abbandonato ecco sto già
avendo un approccio estetico applica un
criterio puramente umano
dell'interpretazione del rapporto madre
figlia anche al capriolo
non sto approcciando mia questo problema
banale quotidiano è un esempio didattico
non parlo di grandi aspetti legati alle
dinamiche naturali
in realtà in migliaia di anni di
evoluzione
la madre del capriolo se adattata a
lasciare soli caprioli perché li tutela
perché non diventa lei stessa una
trattrice di preda di possibili
predatori verso i siti in cui sono
nascosti piccoli di capriolo la mia
buona azione quotidiana è lasciare il
capriolo lì dov'è lasciarlo accudire
dalla madre ho capito il meccanismo come
funziona come funziona questa è la
domanda che mi aspetto per il futuro per
rivoluzionare i nostri rapporti con la
natura come funziona lo studio e la
conoscenza che come diceva einstein
oltre avere un valore in sé al pregio
anche di mantenerci giovani se non nel
fisico a meno nella mente
grazie a tutti per la gente
[Applauso]
[Musica]